vanessa i'm at centennial center off
tropical parkway in the northwest valley
this voting location was actually the
most popular early voting site in the
entire county
and it still seems to be today as people
are lining up this evening
to cast their ballot nearly 27 000
people voted here in october right now
all seems to be going well
voters are waiting about 10 to 15
minutes in line
some even less this afternoon but it may
be picking up as the work day
ends i spoke with a couple ages 71 and
66 were voting for the first time in
their life
they tell me it's an important enough
election to leave the house and cast
their ballot
the couple even commend the efficiency
of this site
it went really smooth you're in and out
in no time to vote so they'll help you
if you have any questions or anything
and it's great
there are 40 machines inside the tent
the election leader tells me
all have been working perfectly today
there was a slight
issue earlier metro had to be called out
and i'm told that's because people were
campaigning too close but that issue did
resolve itself so metro has
left the property now in order to cast a
ballot you must be in line at one of the
125 locations
in clark county by seven o'clock tonight
and you can also come here or
at any of those other locations to drop
off your mail ballot
reporting live in the northwest valley
kristen drummond 8 news now